Бути мамою п'ятьох дітей, наймолодшому з яких лише рік…
Давай, йди до мами! Ну… Хоч трохи покажи, що ти вмієш.
Вести перемовини з волонтерами з усього світу…
І тільки-но повернутися з робочої поїздки на Херсонщину…
З цього зіткане життя Катерини Семенюк - багатодітної мами, капеланки і волонтерки.
Свого наймолодшого сина Луку жінка народила у перший день вторгнення Росії в Україну.
Так, я народила 24-го, це було буквально через 2 години після перших шести ракет,
які приземлилися в нашому місті, які ми фізично чули і бачили.
І потім у бункер нас пустили. Ніч була перша… ми взагалі на зв'язок не виходили.
То діти, коли ми піднялися, вислали фотографії, просто в інтернет вислали, сказали,
що з нами все добре, бо дуже багато родичів писало, друзів.
Ми дуже вдячні всьому світу, насправді зі всього світу писали люди.
Саме тоді Катерина вирішила займатися волонтерством
і вже за півтора місяця поїхала допомагати на деокуповану Київщину.
Ми були всі в шоці, як і вся Україна. Ми просто почали займатися волонтерством,
приймати біженців, надавати їм допомогу волонтерську і також просто моральну,
християнську допомогу, духовну допомогу.
Ми просто почали їздити на деокуповані території, от Буча коли відкрилася, Бородянка.
Ми приїхали туди одразу майже.
Уже понад рік Катерина координує роботу волонтерського центру в Луцьку.
Щоденно сюди привозять гуманітарну допомогу з усього світу.
Так, тут, напевно, лише їжа знаходиться. Ми намагаємося якомога швидше її віддавати.
Ми не віримо в те, що на складах має щось берегтися взагалі.
У нас на складах нічого не затримується довше, ніж 2 тижні.
Все одразу розподіляється чи в бойові зони, чи в деокуповані, чи тут переселенцям.
Серед тонн харчів, одягу та засобів гігієни є речі, які рятують життя українським військовим.
Ми надали запит на турнікети. Особливі турнікети, які йдуть безпосередньо в бригади чи бальйони, і парамедикам.
Це незвичайні турнікети - це SAM. Хто знає їх… парамедики мають знати.
Вони перекривають артерію. Мені пояснили так парамедики: один турнікет - одне життя…
Щоби знайти й доставити в Україну все найнеобхідніше - без вихідних працює ціла команда волонтерів.
Рюкзаки для парамедиків. Ми також зараз маємо запит від них. Бачте? Це Чехія нам надала, ми попросили.
Надихнувшись волонтерством Катерина вирішила, що, крім матеріальної допомоги, хоче надавати й духовну.
Багатодітна мама приєдналася до Корпусу військових капеланів,
який є структурним підрозділом Християнської Служби Порятунку.
На базі підрозділу вона пройшла капеланську підготовку й отримала сертифікат.
Тепер Катерина може їздити на фронт, не вступаючи до лав ЗСУ.
Моя причина особиста - це п'ять дітей. Я не можу підписати контракт із ЗСУ і належати повністю армії, присягати.
Тому що в мене є перша моя місія - це бути матір'ю.
Також є причина, що якщо я вступаю в армію, у лави ЗСУ, я вже не можу займатися волонтерством.
Нині Катерина регулярно їздить на фронт,
де духовно опікається як військовими, так і цивільними.
Я на нулі буваю. По пів дня, часом буває по декілька днів.
Чесно, у мене є дуже хороша охорона: хлопці, в броньованих автомобілях, я в спорядженні, в касці, в бронежилеті.
Тому я не розумію людей, які негативно ставляться до того, мовляв, я мати і їжджу на "нуль".
Я ходжу перед Богом. І мій чоловік підтримує мене. Й не лише чоловік.
Телефон Катерини не знає спокою, адже капеланство не завершується після повернення додому.
Жінка залишається на зв'язку із тими, хто цього потребує, щодня.
Так, пишуть, дзвонять, з позицій дуже часто вони просто пишуть, і ми просто переписуємося.
Дуже часто це просто: "Помоліться, нас дуже сильно криють артилерією", "Дякую за ваші молитви".
Бо ми дуже часто їм пишемо: "Ми за вас молимось, пам'ятайте це.
Ми є тилом вашим, ми вас підтримуємо, ми вас чекаємо, вас любимо.
І ви ні про що не піклуйтесь, ми потурбуємось про ваші сім'ї".
Капеланство і волонтерство займає чимало часу,
тож кожну вільну хвилину Катерина намагається проводити зі своєю родиною.
Маленький Лука, народжений у перший день повномасштабного вторгнення, вже самостійно ходить.
Він Лучик, ми його називаємо Лучик, він постійно посміхається, дуже спокійне дитя.
Ми справді не знаємо, в кого він пішов, бо і чоловік, і я - ми зовсім не інтроверти.
І він дуже позитивний, він такий спокійний у нас.
І часом люди називали його "дитя війни",
але ми називаємо його "дитя миру".
Для мене це принципово, от прямо принципово.